here on the set of Central Intelligence
the new action comedy starring Kevin
Hart and Dwayne Johnson their former
high school classmates turned CIA
operatives the movie sounds awesome and
this scene sounds awesome we are moments
away from Dwayne Johnson getting dropped
off in the scene I'm with Dwayne the
rock Johnson one of the stars of Central
Intelligence you are doing the rock
Johnson I got the right D star well you
know I always say that cuz Kevin Hart's
not here right now
he's not here he may see the video
though so you might wanna might wonder
what do another take on that so you can
just I'm just saying like you know I
don't want to start oh I see what's
happening you're talking me as if I give
up right okay it's clear we can't cut
something let's just we believe we bleep
that's fine
it is 3:45 and do you think that's gonna
make this a worst interview or a way
better interview oh man there's no such
thing as a bad interview I don't I don't
get a bad interview they're all good
your character is was mr. popular in
high school yeah total jock yeah how
close does that come to Kevin Hart a
hundred Cisco Ohio was here said God
everybody in my school if you didn't
know me you wanted to beat me yeah
that's how cool that was I'm lying ah I
used to get hit in the back of my head
with book bags
it was barely did you have to do any
training for this film or we already
sufficiently bad acid not when it comes
to being badass you know yeah
when you look up badassery in the
dictionary which I did your picture is
right next to it my picture is right
next to my okay know what we did was in
many ways in the comedy Kevin is playing
a straight man which is a very
interesting thing on paper but then when
it comes to life on screen and what
we've been putting in these scenes man
it's just been incredible now you're
filming a scene at your high school
reunion your characters high school
ringing yes did you go to your actual
eyes for you uh no no I did not I don't
want to go to my eyes go you'd be mobbed
the reunion they must be the Kevin Hart
show I couldn't do it it'd be like
adding in dangers I couldn't do it I
just don't want them problem yes you can
come to my high school reunion I don't I
don't think I want to go I don't want to
be
we'll just take a pass on that there you
go yeah yeah what let's do the next one
do the net we'll do the 20 here I'm
locked in you heard here Kevin Hart's
gonna be mine 20-year Union definitely
gonna happen are you shaking I said you
know I got one more surprise for you
you have one of my favorite tattoos of
all time if you don't mind me showing
you something let me see
check it out you like that Wow
very very close no that's really good
man especially I know I've really heard
up in there right when you got all the
ink in there man that's sharpie ink in
there really really that's what happens
yeah too right
it's full-on sharpie good good it was a
moment in there where you'll seem you
across that just fix it up I actually
preferred that the public see it I don't
give man this is who I am and I tell you
this I will we'll wrap it up there
thanks for joining us and we need to get
him energy drink
you